Cool. All right. Hello everyone. We're
getting to the back end of the
conference. I don't know if that's a
good thing or not for you. Start the
weekend or maybe sad that the conference
is over. So,
going to be talking about the the
missing primitive for agent swarm. So,
talking a bit about sub-agents and
swarms within the context of of coding
agents and the infrastructure underneath
them.
So, just a quick introduction. So, my
name is Lou. I'm the field CTO at a
company called Owner.
Previous life, I was principal engineer
and sort of platform engineer. Joined
Owner doing product management and now
I'd work a little bit more with our sort
of customers on the field side.
So, in my world at least, everyone is
trying to build a form of a software
factory. I've seen a few different talks
at this conference of similar sort of
ideas trying to take coding agents and
then apply them across the software
development life cycle. I'm wondering
actually if this statement is entirely
correct cuz I definitely chatted to a
lot of people over the course of this
week that are not yet at this point of
thinking about this. But, it's been very
much
occupying my head space for the last a
few months as well. So, I added a
definition in this slide as well just to
quickly define what I believe to be as a
software factory which is sort of the
commitment to incrementally moving the
human out of the loop within the SDLC.
Such that the human is not proactively
interacting with a computer. I say that
because I've seen a few talks and some
people talk about software factory with
these like parallel agents, like one
individual IC running lots of coding
agents at the same time. It's not my
personal definition. My personal
definition is that you're slowly
bringing the human out of it and then
work is flowing from sort of development
into production theoretically in an
automated fashion. But, we're extremely
early in terms of
where we're at with software factories.
So, obviously there's a bunch of funky
little visualizations that I've been
showing and a lot of these are actually
taken from this website
backgroundagents.com that I created
which seem to resonate quite a lot.
So, please do have a look at it. It
encapsulates some of these ideas as
well. But, we have like different
patterns really for running these agents
at scale, coding agents at scale. So,
one of them really is sort of the swarm
pattern which for my definition is
starting off with an
individual intent firing that out to a
number of different agents and then
funneling that back in let's say to an
individual PR or task. And that's almost
like your typical kind of sub-agent
process that we've we've seen quite a
few times. Fleets is something you you
can't see this very well in the room
unfortunately. But, on the top right the
sort of fleets is
where you're fanning out agents across
let's say number of different
repositories inside of an organization
which is a capability we've had in Owner
for quite some time now and you see it a
little bit popping up here or there, but
not so much. But, I think it will be
something that organizations will will
start to take advantage of
a lot more in the future.
And then the bottom you've kind of got
events. So, if you think about how do we
take the human out of the loop and build
this sort of software factory, you need
to know how and when are you going to
trigger those agents, when do they come
online? A lot of this already exists
with existing sort of web hook
infrastructure and things like that. PR
is raised, linear ticket ticket is
created, etc.
One thing that's been useful for us over
the last couple of months is a lot of
these large companies have also come
forward and shared some of their
implementations of this infrastructure.
So,
I'll I'll mention a few notable ones,
but Stripe has one.
There's what they call minions which is
built on top of their existing
infrastructure where they've then
plugged in these coding agents and
they're able to then drive thousands of
pull requests inside of inside of
Stripe.
Another very noteworthy one and Ramp has
been so loud on social media these last
couple of weeks. It's been quite insane.
But, they also built one that they
internally call inspect which again is
their sort of infrastructure for for
running these background agents.
And it's something that we've been doing
now for quite some time.
So, Owner as a platform has been
infrastructure for development
environments for about 6 years. But,
over the last year or two obviously
integrating further with the agent side
of that as well.
What Owner effectively does is allow you
to spin up any number of different
development environments. But, one of
the additional features that we have
that I mentioned is this fleet feature.
So, you can automate on schedules or
triggers agents that spin up to resolve
issues across a number of different
repositories. Like use cases for this is
things like CVE remediation or bumping
test coverage or enforcing something at
scale. As it stands today with current
LLMs, that seems to be often tasks that
are somehow simple. But, the hard part
is that you're doing this across a
number of different teams, thousands of
teams or thousands of repositories.
Which is the what basically I'm showing
you here. So, it works kind of like a
workflow kind of creation. You're adding
prompts, scripts, and things like that
and then using that to to drive this
change across your organization.
I did want to give a notable shoutout
also to the harness engineering blog
that OpenAI and Ryan created because
this encapsulates much of this mindset
of trying to then take and encode as
much of your process into your
repository, into your context files,
your agents.md in order to build
effectively that software factory.
Over the last couple of days I had a few
questions with people talk about harness
engineering and what is it? For me, it's
really another extension on context
engineering whereby everything in your
repository from skills to agents.md to
unit tests, everything that you could
possibly use to give feedback to your
agent is for me harness engineering. So,
I include this little visualization in
the top corner cuz as well for me
harness engineering is very much about
doing things, letting the agent run
through, figuring out where the agents
gets lost and then encoding that
knowledge back into your repository or
context again to try and get the agent
flowing through the software factory as
much as it can.
So, if we take a step back and then
think about from an infrastructure level
what you need effectively to build this
form of sort of software factory, the
first piece of that puzzle is a runtime
or you need somewhere for the agent to
run. And I believe this is mostly is is
pretty much a solved problem now. You
then need a way to orchestrate these.
So, you need to run them at scale. So,
you need to await to run these agents
you know, scale up, scale down
horizontally.
You need some way to trigger them. But,
for me one of the biggest difficulties
if you try and build this today is
effectively agent coordination. So, how
do you get the agents to sort of
interact with each other, pick up tasks
from each other, how do they
collaborate?
For runtimes, lots of you know,
different approaches here. But, you can
run agents in separate threads. You can
isolate them more in work trees. You can
then go one step of abstraction further
and put them in containers and VMs or
micro VMs or what Owner does basically
we we really call these dev
environments. So, like the sandbox
conversation has made this very blurry.
But, we at least believe that for
running sort of proper development
tasks, it has to be inside of a virtual
machine. The reason for that is for the
isolation from a security standpoint, a
container is not bulletproof
isolation boundary. So, if you have an
agent running in there and you want to
secure it, you this challenge is for a
container. They're also bursty. If you
run them on Kubernetes or in pods, you
have noisy neighbor problems. You're
going to have compute contention across
different containers.
And only with having sort of the full
isolation of a VM
will you be able to effectively do this
properly. Let me run back through my
presentation, sorry.
Cool. So, let me actually just quickly
It's a good point actually at this
point. I will show you a quick demo of
how this actually looks inside of the
Owner interface because a lot of this is
a little bit theoretical.
I did a quick recording of this
yesterday in my hotel room just in case
the Wi-Fi was terrible in here. But, let
me just run you through this. So,
in here you see the Owner interface. On
the left-hand side, you have all the
different tasks that I have running. So,
I kicked off two different tasks here.
The first one I I asked Owner to
implement me Symphony. So, Symphony has
a spec in the repository that talks
about how to implement Symphony. It's a
very detailed spec. So, I wanted to use
it as an example. I gave one of the
agent and asked it to spin this up using
process-based agents. So, sub-agents
running within the environment itself.
So, take the VM, run the agent inside
and that agent will spin up sub-agents
within that VM. The other one I asked it
to is effectively to run me a fleet with
a number of different VMs. So, the agent
is actually then empowered
to create other VMs inside of the
platform and it can spin up technically
infinite of these. So, wherever you're
running this, you're only really
inhibited by as much as your cloud
provider can scale we see and I might
have to skip through here a little bit
is we see
I jumped too fast.
This bottom agent, the VM one,
then it will spawn these three different
sub-agents. So, it spins up the
different VMs which we see coming in on
the left-hand side. The the parent is
the the controlling agent and the
sub-agents obviously then are given
small bits of contact, individual tasks
to complete and then will do message
passing back to that parent agent to
control and govern the overall task
itself.
One challenge for sure we have is that
how do we build the UX for this? Like as
you build more and more complicated
tasks, how do you think about sort of
managing and controlling these
sub-agents and how do you think about
the UX on top of them?
So, as this progresses, you'll see also
on the left-hand side eventually you
start to see
as the agents come online, they start
their environments and they start to
work through tasks. Both of these have
for some reason seven sort of sub-items
that they're working through. So, you
can see those. When it gets to the end,
it's then obviously going to terminate
those VMs. That's all going to collapse
down and your task is is complete.
The second form of UX for this that we
have with the the sub-agents is this one
here with the process level which I'll
pause so that it's not jumping around.
When you launch your process level
sub-agent, it happens all within the
single agent window. So, you actually
see at the bottom here a stack of a
number of different sub-agents that are
starting. And then when you click on
those, you can then open up a new chat
window which is almost your new context
and use that. So, you've got this like
two different forms of this. One
entirely isolated VMs to scale out these
swarms and another one at the sort of
process level where you can run it
within the individual VM itself.
So, there's a lot of stuff going on
there, but I wanted to show you
conceptually people say, "What does a
swarm look like in in in reality? How
does this actually look?" And this is
how it looks within within ONA.
So, give me 1 second to fly back
through.
So, coming back to the software factory
idea. So, how do I know about some of
the challenges about software factories?
And that is because I've also tried to
build one.
Obviously, I implement many of these
ideas in in our own projects, but I
also, similarly to what OpenAI did
building out their sort of symphony
projects and their harness engineering
blog, is okay, what can we build a
project without touching any lines of
code? And can we automate as much of
this process as possible such that the
agent can actually then develop
everything as autonomously and
self-driven as possible.
And it turns out yes, the technology is
there today, but there are some
different challenges that you have.
What's missing?
One thing that we you find out is that
the SDLC is not
this. It you know, this is the
conceptual SDLC that we present and talk
about with each other. Very
coarse-grained five steps of the SDLC.
Agents don't respect this and they don't
understand I mean, these boxes contain a
ton of complexity. So, if we take
something like plan or plan stage,
actually within that our SDLC has a ton
of different sort of micro steps almost
to it. And if we're wanting them to
train agents to then step through the
SDLC, we need to find ways to actually
break down the SDLC into these some of
these micro steps. And that happens all
the way through the SDLC.
So, if you want to build some form of
software factory, we then now need to
start figuring out how to solve these
sort of micro steps. How do we get
agents to sufficiently follow those
steps and do them in sort of
deterministic ways as well?
And the hard part of this is context.
Probably not a
you know, huge innovation to everyone in
this room. Context windows are some of
the hardest parts about working with
LLMs because as the last speaker said
here as well, context rot.
Context, you know, once the context
window becomes consumed, the the agent
starts to lose track of where it's going
and things like that. It gets less
effective. They also skip steps
typically.
You know, they want to please us.
They're quite sycophantic, so they will
might, you know, ask them to write some
tests and then they'll going to skip
some tests
in order to complete the task.
So, a lot of the tools that we have
today as well for coordinating these
agents as you start to spin them up.
Once you got this infrastructure, you
have the runtimes, you have the
orchestration, the missing piece that
you also need is coordination. So, if
you use something like GitHub, GitHub is
not a coordination layer for agents. It
gets incredibly overwhelming. You know,
you can have your agents raise a pull
request, you can review it, you can then
solve the merge conflicts, you can fix
the CI build, etc. But this gets
incredibly noisy for you as a human to
make sense of where you should step in
to intervene with that agent itself. And
GitHub is a a poor solution for this.
Uh Symphony is built on top of linear,
but suffers the same problem that we're
reusing existing sort of human tools in
very weird ways for agents.
But I think we are now at the cusp of
now effectively solving this. And I
think it might be solved in a few
different ways. One is
through sort of state machines,
you know, by building out workflows and
effectively state machines that we've
had for a very long time and then
building these as our versions of our
SDLC. I do believe to a degree some of
the ideas from durable executions comes
into this as well. You know, lots of
companies have pioneered this over time
to be able to run a process in a in a
durable fashion.
Um but we do need to solve also the
gates and compliance section of this.
And I do believe actually there is
definitely a a gap right now also for
packaging this in some form of like CLI
construct whereby you can run this
locally in a sort of development
environment, but also then remotely in,
you know, in a CI or some other fashion
like this.
But that's effectively if anyone wants
to to chat and go a little bit deeper, I
think we got a couple of minutes. We can
also take some some questions if we need
to.
Yes, basically my definition of software
factory is moving this human on the loop
so that they're not necessarily driving
each of these individual changes.
Context and context management is by far
the hardest part of building this
software factory.
Out of these primitives, I do believe
we've effectively solved the runtime.
There are many options for this now,
sandboxes and and containers and other
solutions. The orchestration is
effectively solved. The triggers are
solved, but the thing that's missing for
me is coordination.
Also, one of our folks here is here from
from our security team. And security is
another piece of the the puzzle that we
really need to solve as well to to drive
more automation.
But it's this coordination layer that I
think is is largely what's missing.
Obviously, a lot of this is a little bit
high-level. On the 6th of May, we'll run
a virtual summit to go into these topics
about software
software factories and background
agents. So, if anyone here would like to
attend, you can do. It's on
backgroundagents.com and there's we have
a CFP up for it as well. If anyone would
like to speak, that would also be great.
There's not many people in the world
doing this. So, if you're at least
experimenting with it, would be great to
also to talk to you as well.
The other thing is a few people that
I've been speaking to at the conference
especially about software factory
complained that obviously a lot of these
talks are a little bit theoretical,
which is true. So, some of you might
want to be really getting into the weeds
of this. So, actually next week
with Zach from ONA, we're actually just
going to build one of these in public
starting from scratch, build a software
factory. We'll we'll do this over the
course of 2 weeks in public to show what
that looks like with today's technology
just to really like show all the ins and
outs of the workflows if anyone wants to
see what that actually looks like as
well.
There you go. Thank you very much.
We do have 2 and 1/2 minutes if anyone
has questions, but if not, I'll also be
outside and downstairs. Yes. Thank you
for the the talk. Super helpful. Could
you
go back to the slide where you were
talking about the problems with the
coordination layer? Yep.
Memory and then also if you could just
elaborate a bit more on what you propose
as a solution in more concrete.
Um that would be pretty interesting to
hear about.
Yeah, sure. So, I have been So, I need
to repeat the question actually for the
for the stream. So, the question was
problems with the coordination layer and
sort of more concreteness about the
solution. What could that potentially
look like? So, I have
We have a number of different sort of
prototypes for this internally and I've
also been trying to think about how we
what do we do with this? So, I think one
form factor that that works is the CLI.
So, I've seen some other solutions,
graph-based ones. There are some
open-source things right now where
defining the workflow effectively as a
as a graph. Um you know, like kind of
like what you drive sort of mermaid
diagrams out of like NA10 type of of
workflows. Um where you can define sort
of these prompts in in that form. Um I
think that ultimately needs to be
packaged in some form of CLI though.
What I mean by that is I think that if
you have a local running agent, cloud
code, whatever, any local running CLI, I
think that now needs to have something
that integrates with its tool so it can
invoke this to say, "Hey, have I
achieved this part of my SDLC and can I
now proceed to the next part of it as a
a CLI?" If you want as well, I can have
a full spec for this. I can show you
after the talk as well. We can go a bit
deeper into it. Um
but I'm seeing this solved in a number
of different ways. People are solving
this in in a few different ways. There's
the NA10 sort of
workflow type of diagram way. The CLI
sort of gateway of is the prototype that
I have as well.
And then there's an a range of different
sort of hacky interim solutions. There's
one even the open claw folks have as
well, which the name is eluding me, but
I will I think ACPX, which they built on
top of ACP. Um which builds out some of
this workflow. There's a GitHub one,
Fabro. Some folks are playing around
with, but it's very nascent right now.
Um
Yeah.
Any other questions?
Are you using Are you using some
protocol for the CLI? Because you have
ACP, there's ACP that's eight way.
There's a bunch of
Yeah, I I don't know if we don't know
the standard.
Currently not. So, the inter the
implementation I have, I'm trying to
understand whether or not to like
release it as an implementation or as a
standard to be honest because I largely
kind of don't really care about the
implementation. I almost care about the
the standard for it so we can
collaborate on the standard.
Um but it's not built on top of ACP, at
least not yet, but it might be. Is it
eight way either?
Not eight way either, no.
It's solving I feel like a slightly
different problem space, so.
Cool.
All right. Thank you very much. Enjoy
the conference, everyone. Thank you.